por favor piense en los empobrecidos de
francia también es por eso que estoy
aquí estoy pensando viven en la miseria
y por eso estamos luchando por las
ayudas al empleo soy profesor y lo veo
aquí hay gente que se muere de hambre ya
veo gracias por pensar en ellos gracias
mil veces un día después de ganar la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales el trabajo continúa y el
presidente manuel macrón visitó el norte
de francia entreno donde su rival obtuvo
más del 41% de los votos un feudo de
clase obrera hostil al mandatario llega
no hay que utilizar falsas promesas para
tranquilizar hay que hacerlo con
compromisos profundos con una dirección
y eso se hace con más educación
hay que intentar desarrollar a los
barrios más densamente poblados y hay
que seguir poniendo más medias menos
prisa ha tenido mark independent iniciar
su gira en el día 1 de campaña para la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales la líder de extrema
derecha decidió quedarse en parís para
reunirse con su equipo y firmar algún
autógrafo
antes de visitar pueblos pequeños y
zonas rurales francesas dio
declaraciones el líder de su partido el
frente nacional somos humildes recibimos
esos resultados con mucha humildad pero
creo que marine lepén será elegido el
presidente en unos días porque creo que
la mayoría de los franceses el 70 por
ciento no votaron por él manuel máxima
con los sondeos dan como favorito a
emanuel macrón actual presidente de
francia sin embargo en las últimas
semanas mal indepen ha ganado cada vez
más apoyos concentrando su campaña en el
alto coste de la vida para los franceses
en plena subida de precios de
combustibles y alimentos